charms how are you doing buddy I'm good
my brother before below him in the
playoffs oh my life is good it's just
funny right now it's Richardson man we
just want a chat about this day because
it does it looks like you guys have so
much fun first of all man I just love
watching you have it so much fun on that
show man well Mike you know it's just
basketball we're not solving any
problems in the world
we got like no real stuff going on we're
not like teachers and farmers police and
people got real jobs we got a bunch of
guys who making 10 20 30 million dollars
a year
Chuck Chuck you save some interesting
things while watching these playoffs
here and in last night watching you guys
you say some interesting things first
give me your overall as your overall
thoughts on what you've seen in the
playoffs so far well I think we're right
what we thought we were going to be I
don't think there's been any surprises
if you go back and look at the second
round of the playoffs as the top four
teams so they're there haven't been any
upsets we knew the Warriors were going
to be had a hands full with the Rockets
doesn't it dip in Portland are two
sleepers and they got they tied 2-2 in
the East Milwaukee was the best team all
year and the Philly Toronto series was a
toss-up and it looks like Philly blew it
losing the last game at home and I koala
litter has been the best player in the
NBA
and the playoffs but I don't think
there's been any surprises to be honest
with you Mike
hey Charles this is Mitch here what's up
my man yeah I'm doing great bro I'm
doing great so you said that you thought
Milwaukee couldn't win it all give us
your thoughts on on if you see them
matching up with Houston or matching up
with both and state why do you think
that that team can get over the hump
with the Western Conference guys because
nobody can guard that Greek free kids
here's first of all Mitch he reminds me
of guys from our generation he we
watched his press conference last night
he says
we're not done yet we got one more
handle Williams you got to come out and
do what we got to do you know he
wouldn't celebrate I love the fact last
night they got greedy
you know Mitch you been on teams when
you get to split your content no they
came out last night no no no but Celtics
is not good as we are
let's go ahead and end this thing in
five games that's what impressed me more
than anything last night
you know expected for a young team with
a young superstar you know most teams
would be like okay we got the home court
back they're like no let's get greedy
and he dominated and now those other
guys are playing well and to beat
Milwaukee man you don't have to play
well whoever comes out of the West
they're gonna have any hands full
because Brik freak is planned with such
a confidence and those other guys are
feeding off of him and like I say I
think taking how they're gonna win the
East and it's gonna be tough anybody
they play yeah I said to Mike if if
confucian you know if Houston beats
Golden State I think it's wide open but
I do agree with you about on Yanis
because one thing about him is that he
doesn't talk all of this talking is is
all about on the court and he goes full
speed every possession and Jos a young
team young superstar the other team has
a young team with a young superstar in
Kyrie Irving how do you see that playing
out with Kyrie now I on Boston being
there about to get eliminated well that
was a social experiment that whole
season Mike if you go back I said that's
beginning out of season I says you know
there's everybody to pick Boston away in
the East I said oh y'all need to slow
your roll just cause these guys made it
to Game seven last year and they getting
two all-stars back that's not gonna be
easy and exactly what I thought was
gonna happen all year is happening they
don't they're not together they got a
bunch of offensive
players who mean they only got a couple
guys on that team who's gonna sacrifice
it don't care about scoring and that's
Al Horford and Marcus smart the rest of
the guys they're all offensive players
hey that's not a one ball to go around
out there and if you've got a BA versus
guys are just standing around saying
when is my turn that's exactly what
happened this season it didn't work it's
not going to work
and it's gonna be very interesting what
they do this summer what they do what
Boston does or what Kyrie does well
combination you know because you know I
don't think he's gonna stay in Boston
but even if he does say they got to
trade some of those other places the way
they got it mass right now is not going
to work plain and simple they just they
got too many guys who want the ball i
mike you know you've been on great teams
before misspent on some really really
good teams if you don't have guys who
want to sacrifice who say you know what
i'm content to just play defense rebound
I'm not worried about my minutes and
things like that and I've been on teams
like that when you got everybody
thinking like when is my turn to shoot
the ball it always ends badly and that's
what happened with the Celtics and you
listen to Charles Barkley here on the
Rich Eisen show I'm Michael Irvin
standing here for Rich Eisen along with
NBA Hall of Famer Mitch Richmond here
Charles you bringing up stuff when you
talk about guys playing their part and
everything now let's flip over when
you're watching Golden State and we're
talking about this early on as we sat
around a minute
your watch coach is going to state more
prone to losing now that they have Kevin
Durant because of the way they play
through Kevin Durant do you think it's
some way some way that is possibly
diminished a team well what I said last
night was I think they become too
reliant there's a couple problems they
got I think they become what happened in
the first round of the playoffs they
start exploring the Patrick Beverley
the hit the mismatch against Katie so
now it's a remember when Katie just
start posting them up and he just score
every time I think they becomes that's
what they rely on too much but I think
the biggest problem is when they move I
get down to the starting lineup Dana
they depth is gone cuz now
iguodala's gonna get he's getting tired
now cuz he's dis problem most minutes
he's played all year Brandon Livingston
not rented leviston Shaun Livingston is
not the same player they bench is not as
good as it's been the last few years and
I think it's really starting to catch up
with them that's why I don't think they
gonna make it to the finals whether they
win this series or not I don't think
they gonna make it to the finals because
they're deaf it suspect clay is tired if
he's chasing James Harden around and so
it's a lot of legacy but I think the
depth is really start to hurt those guys
but the main thing is they they have
become too reliant on Kevin because it
was working against the Clippers and
let's be fair it's working against the
Rockets but Steph has not been able to
get into rhythm and clay has definitely
not been able to get into rhythm yeah
you so right and we were talking earlier
and I said you know you you you touched
on when you're talking about your good
player your great player like in Kyrie
that he has I think he has to take a
step back sometimes and get everybody
else involved because he's so talented
he can always turn it on when he needs
to
I think Golden State is in that process
- because I'm in that situation -
because they don't have a bench like
that so when they get when they get klay
Thompson started early
there they are a better team cuz we know
curry can feed off of anything
Durant can get his shot any time he
wants but they have to make sure that
clay be that third they are that first
option first because he needs to get
going early
well because clay to me is the one who
was on to read it because what he does
he gives those other guys space because
you can't leave clay but
nonce Linga even if you put off of him
he can get a shot off so he gives
camping and stuff a lot of room and so
when they don't get him going
it really hurts their team I officially
you go back and look with me what he
store to go back to the Oklahoma City
stairs and he scored like 40 to get them
when they were down 3-1
he makes life easier for everybody else
cuz he's the one guy you can't leave
open everybody knows that and you just
see it has a tear on them and a wear on
them nachos you seen some early and I
want to get back to it you said Kawhi
Leonor best player in the NBA
know in these playoffs okay Yanis is the
best player he said who are you saying
is the best player right now who is the
real king sister King is no longer in
these playoffs well you don't like you
don't get to get it this ain't good
you don't get a Lifetime Achievement
Award Katie be honest why they right
there with LeBron LeBron has been the
best player in NBA for a long time but
you don't get to keep it forever right
and I think what you have seen in these
playoffs you can access a you can
depending on your flavor I mean just
depending on your flavor you can
actually say one of these guys or let's
be realistic
the winning a plan you would have to say
all three of those players are better
than the brunt and that's not a knock I
mean I want to see these guys for the
last two weeks and I'm thinking like yo
man these guys are and nobody's playing
better than Yanis and Kawhi nobody and
came to rest right there I put out
LeBron don't get to keep the best player
of my toe forever and you're listening
to Charles Barkley on the Rich Eisen
show I am Mike Corbitt standing in for
rich eyes in with along with NBA Hall of
Famer matrix let me just get this right
because you know I did a you know I just
wanna make sure I heard
you've got right now Cady Kauai Yanis in
a LeBron you got LeBron it's the fourth
best player in the NBA right now is that
will you just not in the playoffs man
I'm saying first of all it's up to your
flavor of the month another one but I
think you've got a fair argument after
watching these playoffs that deem three
guys are better players than LeBron now
LeBron is not standing to represent
himself but if you are Yanis fan or Katy
fan or Kawhi Leonard fan you got a fair
argument who the best player in the
world is right now plain and simple
I'll be me and I don't think it I don't
think it's a stretch hey no LeBron is
great but right now the brothers not
there but those three guys I just
mentioned they are flat-out balling
right now played it simple
yeah well I agree with your sauce I
think John is for me and and and and I
think I think Katie is probably the best
scorer and and and with and with harden
but I think from he's on the defensive
end he's rebounding he's assisting he's
doing everything he's going full-speed
every player of the game that guy and
he's willing his team to win so I think
he just comes with a different energy to
me and then kind you got a look at Lynn
or two he's like that too but I bow
Yanis I'll go Yanis right Mike listen
okay you guys yes it ain't like you can
say well that's not close well what
we've seen and rest of all all year
LeBron didn't have a great year let's
get that out the way he did not have a
great year but what these three guys are
doing in the playoffs you can actually
say
man one of these guys got an argument is
being the best player in the world
playing it simple right now all right
right now right now I think that's
making news right between the [ __ ]
check it you say you got Milwaukee
before we let you go Milwaukee over who
in the finals well I picked up all of
trailblazers to get to the finals they
let me down the other night saw blowing
that so they could have won her up 3-1
but I'm gonna stick with them I picked
them I can't change my mind
now I got the Portland Trailblazers
going to the finals okay brothers for a
long time
playmaker when you sent me the text man
you know I got number love and respect
for you and Mitch Mitch is one of the
most underrated I mean I don't know how
to hear you on the radio doing all the
fame great players great people I
haven't been around some man for more
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app